i support enthusiastically
the sending of mig aircraft from poland
my personal feeling is we should provide
those planes i haven't met anybody in
the senate who's not in favor of seeing
those migs get into ukraine
as calls to send migs to ukraine grow
larger by the day louder by the day we
want to take a step back and ask
is that wise would it even make much of
a difference at this point
uh and who is in ukraine who has the
actual skills which are considerable
to fly those planes
these are relevant questions and
something a senate armed services
committee chair jack reed addressed
today
you say that as a distraction because
they simply couldn't fly them
effectively anyway explain well they
have a number of
mig aircrafts itself and they're flying
very few sorted that could be a
combination of
lack of support mechanics fuel
the safety of the pilots in the air the
lack of pilots
joining me now is arkansas senator tom
cotton who also sits on the armed
services committee senator
you do not agree
with that assessment why
i don't laura first i want to say that
i'm very grateful to hear greg palket's
report and uh anna and i on behalf of
all our kansans continuing to send
prayers to benji hall and his family i
know it's been a very tough day tough
week for you and the whole fox news
family we're very sorry for your losses
uh for pierre the cameraman and sasha
the interpreter that we're working with
benji but we're glad to hear he's doing
okay
they're just three more innocent
civilian victims uh among thousands in
vladimir putin's
brutal war of aggression
i don't agree with jack reed's
assessment i do think that
president zielinski and the ukrainian
army has proven
that they can take this fight to the
russians they can close their own skies
if we support them with the weapons and
aircraft they need now these mig
aircraft are not a silver bullet laura
there are no silver bullets in warfare
it is about the total mix of weapons and
vehicles and aircrafts you could bring
to bear
but ukraine has these aircraft they're
familiar with flying them poland is
willing to send them it was ridiculous
for the secretary of state to say we
greenlighted the transfer one day and
then two days later say that would be
escalatory if the united states
transferred them president biden once
again
is on the back foot
he needs to be where president zielinski
urged him to be today which is leading
the world in helping ukraine fight for
their own freedom biden can't lead the
united states senator cotton with all
due respect i mean when i hear when i
hear president
biden being told you need to lead the
world first of all you know with all due
respect to you know president zielinski
is obviously incredibly heroic
you know
he he's fighting for his country as he
should but we have a president who's as
i said in the angle essentially a
hologram
he is not an active president defending
our interests here let alone the
president of the world
so i mean i think going down that road
is kind of ridiculous at this point
yeah
what he could do is just stop engaging
in half measures uh that are a day late
and dollar short you know last week
laura for instance he came out and gave
a very chesty speech about how we were
going to ban the import of oil into
america from russia we're still
importing russian oil they had a month
and a half long wind down period of that
so we're still still sending on average
more than 20 million
dollars a day
to russia's war machine
this goes back for months so laura you
have had president uh biden who's
continually been a day late in a dollar
short whether he's dragged along by the
bravery and the courage that the
ukrainian army is displayed or by
members of congress and frankly by
members of congress in both parties in
many cases i mean just look today they
announced the transfer of 800 million
dollars of weapons to ukraine this
welcome should have been done a month
ago or two months ago and it's still
just a fraction of what congress
proposed last week look the ukrainian
people and army have proven that they
are capable of fighting the russians we
need to encourage them to do so and we
need to provide the weapons that they
need to fight the russians now you don't
think you don't think we're giving
the ukrainians at this point and the
rest of the world false hope
you think that you think given the fact
that russia is closing in on ukraine at
this moment you heard the air raid
sirens outside of la vie
that that we're not building people up
to this false hope at this point i'm
worried about that
given the fact that still so many people
are in those cities i'm worried
laura i really don't uh one of the
reasons you're hearing air raid sirens
across ukraine is that the russian army
has failed in its first plan
to encircle these cities and force their
capitulation
kiva is being hit with missiles and
artillery because the russian army
cannot encircle key they've been trying
to do so for three weeks they were no
closer today than they were so yes there
is still a lot of bloodshed in ukraine
russia is still engaged in
indiscriminate bombing of civilian areas
that's because they have not been able
to achieve their military objectives and
if we provided them not only with migs
but with the kind of anti-missile
defense systems and anti-aircraft
systems that they're pleading for
they could help close their own skies
laura
and you think senator at this point a
peace negotiations which i said in the
angle it seems like
you don't hear anybody not many in the
senate and certainly not biden
really indicating that there's much
interest in res you know having this
stop tonight like come come to an end
the focus is getting the migs or getting
the missiles or getting more weapons a
billion dollars here a billion dollars
there but it looks like they're fairly
close to an agreement at this point
would would you
be supportive of that
i would welcome a piece of agreement
that stops the bloodshed in ukraine uh
it's not really for us though to
negotiate that or certainly to impose it
upon
the ukrainian people that's a choice for
them to make led by president zielinski
led by president zielinski
but i don't think americans whether
they're in the congress or whether
they're in this administration should be
dictating those terms but if president
zielinski uh representing the ukrainian
people can reach a peace agreement um he
needs to he'll need to do so from a
position of strength that's one reason
why he needs these weapons that stops
the bloodshed and preserves ukraine's
freedom uh then i think that would be a
welcome development not only for ukraine
but for the world
senator thank you as always for coming
on we really appreciate it